the winter storm this holiday weekend is
likely to cause big problems at airports
all across the country all major US
airlines are now allowing passengers due
to fly in the path of the storm to
change their flights for free the storm
is likely to add to the stress that
airport workers feel because of the
government shutdown and that shutdown
has now lasted 28 days Kris Van Cleave
is at Washington's Reagan National
Airport where they're expecting more of
the worst Kris good morning good morning
it is expected to be a busy travel
weekend at airports coast-to-coast we're
hearing about unusually long lines at
the Minneapolis Airport this morning and
the TSA is acknowledging there's a
certain amount of uncertainty here
because it really depends on how many of
the TSA screeners at your airport can
afford to come to work for yet another
day without pay dozens of protesters at
Honolulu Airport demand an end to the
government shutdown and paychecks for
some of the 2,700 federal workers in
Hawaii
the TSA continues to struggle with
staffing as officers nationwide are
calling out unable to afford working
without pay in Fort Lauderdale TSA
screeners lined up to get free groceries
from a non profit this right here means
a lot because I mean not a lot of people
are thinking how hard is affecting us
until they're like you know what we
don't know how long this is gonna be and
everyday people dropped off donations at
Orlando's Airport
in Houston help came in the form of a
food truck a non-profit there gave away
300 free lunches to TSA workers outside
Bush Intercontinental Airport in
Sacramento California governor Gavin
Newsom met with TSA officers and other
airport workers burning through their
savings I'm staying afloat on what's
left of my savings Newsom announced
California would offer furloughed
workers unemployment benefits despite
the US Labor Department saying the state
did not have the right to do so and in
the Bay Area San Jose is offering
short-term no interest loans of up to
$7,500 for unpaid airport employees we
recognize it's our role to operate a
safe airport and you can't do that
without air traffic controllers and
customs inspectors and TSA officials
United Airlines bought lunch for TSA
workers here at Reagan National
yesterday and if this shutdown goes
through past the middle of next week
the TSA is going to miss a second
paycheck should also tell you the
shutdown is having an impact on the DC
metro system here buses in Subway's
they're losing four hundred thousand
dollars a day in reduced ridership be
honest I know I will be extra kind to
TSA officials when I travel this weekend
as well Chris thank you